[Música]
el 4 de julio de 2015 la nave espacial
de NASA New horizons estaba a 5 billones
de kilómetros de la tierra
estaba a solo 10 días de Plutón después
de volar 9.5 años cuando de repente se
quedó sin contacto pero retrocedamos un
poco a partir de 1989 la humanidad había
enviado con éxito naves a cada planeta
del sistema solar excepto uno Plutón
habrás oído que los astrónomos no
consideran a Plutón o a sus hermanos
planetas sin embargo la mayoría de los
científicos planetarios lo hacen por lo
cual usamos esa terminología aquí es
limitado lo que podemos aprender de
Plutón desde la tierra porque está muy
alejado de nosotros Plutón sin embargo
es una mina de oro científica está
localizado en llamada el cinturón de
hyper hogar de muchos planetas pequeños
cientos de miles de ancianos objetos
helados y trillones de Cometas
esta Misteriosa región contiene pistas
de la formación de nuestro sistema solar
y estaba tentadoramente lejos de nuestro
alcance hasta New horizons su objetivo
explorar Plutón recoger todos los datos
científicos que sea posible
transmitirlos de vuelta a la tierra
luego explorar más lejos en el cinturón
de kyber para conseguirlo del equipo de
New horizons equipó su nave con
instrumentos científicos de tecnología
de punta estos incluyen a Ralph un
conjunto de cámaras tan potente para
capturar las características del tamaño
de los edificios de Manhattan desde
decenas hasta miles de kilómetros de
distancia y Rex diseñado para usar ondas
de radio para medir la presión
atmosférica de Plutón y su temperatura
todo el equipo a bordo tenía que ser a
la vez confiable y ligero porque el New
horizons tenía un reto adicional tenía
que alcanzar su objetivo lo antes
posible
Por qué alrededor de 2020 Plutón
alcanzará un punto en su órbita donde la
atmósfera podría congelarse y debido a
la inclinación de su eje cada vez más
superficie de Plutón está envuelta en
oscuridad cada año
Plutón completa Una órbita completa una
vez cada 248 años sería una larga espera
hasta la siguiente oportunidad de
visitarlo
para ver como New horizons llegó a
Plutón a tiempo avancemos hasta su
lanzamiento sus tres cohetes
estadificadores aceleraron a una
velocidad tan grande que cruzó los
400.000 kilómetros hacia la luna en solo
9 horas
cerca de un año después la nave alcanzó
Júpiter y obtuvo lo que llamamos un
asistente gravitatorio Ahí es donde
fuera lo suficientemente cerca del
gigante gaseoso para recibir un efecto
gravitacional de tirachinas entonces New
horizons estaba volando acerca de 50.000
kilómetros por hora como lo haría los
siguientes ocho años para cruzar el
golfo restante de Plutón ir a una
velocidad tan asombrosa significa que la
desaceleración para entrar en órbita o
aterrizar habría sido imposible es por
eso que New horizons estaba en misión de
sobrevuelo tenía una sola oportunidad de
pasar sobre Plutón y hacer observaciones
el sobrevuelo sería totalmente
automático ya que a esa distancia los
intentos de guiarlo a la tierra
tardarían 4.5 horas en llegar
el equipo puso un ordenador de abordo
con cientos de órdenes llamado código
madre que comenzaría a trabajar cuando
la nave estuviera a 6.5 días de Plutón
pero cuando a New horizons le quedaban
10 días para llegar casi ocurrió una
tragedia el control de tierra perdió
contacto con la nave después de dos
angustiosas horas New horizons volvió
online pero el control descubrió que el
ordenador principal se había reiniciado
perdiendo el código madre y otra
información crítica
sin eso pasarías un bando junto a Plutón
sin nada que mostrar a la misión
Alice bowmann la jefa de operaciones de
la misión lideró un equipo por 72 horas
en vela para conseguir que las
instrucciones fueran cargadas de nuevo
en el New horizons a tiempo sin espacio
para errores ella y su equipo lo
lograron y New horizons empezó a tomar y
retransmitir imágenes impresionantes
estas observaciones han revelado un
mundo deliciosamente variado con nieblas
terrestres calima a alta altitud
posibles nubes cañones montañas
imponentes fallas cráteres casquetes
polares glaciares aparentes campos de
dunas sospechosos volcanes de hielo
evidencia de fluidos pasados y mucho más
un descubrimiento emocionante es el
glaciar sputnik planilla de 1000 km de
ancho
sputnik planilla Está compuesto por
nitrógeno congelado batido y nunca hemos
visto nada como esto en nuestro sistema
solar
la exploración de Plutón fue un gran
éxito pero New horizons aún no había
acabado en enero de 2019 batió su propio
récord por el objeto más lejano
explorado cuando visitó un objeto del
cinturón de kyper llamado arroc que
orbita alrededor del sol otros miles de
millones de kilómetros más lejos que
Plutón el mundo contiene el aliento para
ver qué encontraremos a continuación
Plutón puede parecer bastante lejano
pero no si se lo compara con digamos los
límites del universo Tómese un momento
para considerar Qué tan grande es el
infinito con este video
[Música]